CLEMENS MEWALD: Hi, everyone.
My name is Clemens.
I'm a product manager
in Google Research.
And today I'm going to talk
about TensorFlow Extended,
which is a machine learning
platform that we built
around TensorFlow at Google.
And I'd like to start
this talk with a block
diagram and the small
yellow box, or orange box.
And that box
basically represents
what most people care about
and talk about when they
talk about machine learning.
It's the machine
learning algorithm.
It's the structure
of the network
that you're training,
how you choose
what type of machine learning
problem you're solving.
And that's what you talk about
when you talk about TensorFlow
and using TensorFlow.
However, in addition to the
actual machine learning,
and to TensorFlow
itself, you have
to care about so much more.
And these are all of
these other things
around the actual machine
learning algorithm
that you have to have in
place, and that you actually
have to nail and
get right in order
to actually do machine learning
in a production setting.
So you have to care about
where you get your data from,
that your data are clean,
how you transform them,
how you train your model,
how to validate your model,
how to push it out into
a production setting,
and deploy it at scale.
Now, some of you may
be thinking, well,
I don't really need all of this.
I only have my small
machine learning problem.
I can live within
that small orange box.
And I don't really have these
production worries as of today.
But I'm going to
propose that all of you
will have that problem
at some point in time.
Because what I've
seen time and time
again is that research
and experimentation
today is production tomorrow.
It's like research and
experimentation never
ends just there.
Eventually it will become
a production model.
And at that point, you
actually have to care about all
of these things.
Another side of
this coin is scale.
So some of you may
say, well, I do
all of my machine learning on
a local machine, in a notebook.
Everything fits into memory.
I don't need all of these
heavy tools to get started.
But similarly, small scale
today is large scale tomorrow.
At Google we have this
problem all the time.
That's why we always design
for scale from day one,
because we always have
product teams that say, well,
we have only a small
amount of data.
It's fine.
But then a week later
the product picks up.
And suddenly they need to
distribute the workload
to hundreds of machines.
And then they have
all of these concerns.
Now, the good news is that
we built something for this.
And TFX is the solution
to this problem.
So this is a block
diagram that we published
in one of our papers that
is a very simplistic view
of the platform.
But it gives you a
broad sense of what
the different components are.
Now, TFX is a very
large platform.
And it contains a
lot of components
and a lot of services.
So the paper that we
published, and also
what I'm going to discuss today,
is only a small subset of this.
But building TFX and
deploying it at Google
has had a profound impact of
how fast product teams at Google
can train machine
learning models
and deploy them in production,
and how ubiquitous machine
learning has become at Google.
You'll see later I have a slide
to give you some sense of how
widely TFX is being used.
And it really has accelerated
all of our efforts
to being an AI first company
and using machine learning
in all of our products.
Now, we use TFX
broadly at Google.
And we are very
committed to make
all of this available to you
through open sourcing it.
So the boxes that are
just highlighted in blue
are the components that
we've already open sourced.
Now, I want to highlight
an important thing.
TFX is a real solution
for real problems.
Sometimes people ask me, well,
is this the same code that you
use at Google for production?
Or did you just build something
on the side and open source it?
And all of these components
are the same code base
that we use internally for
our production pipelines.
Of course, there's
some things that
are Google specific
for our deployments.
But all of the code
that we open source
is the same code
that we actually
run in our production systems.
So it's really code that solves
real problems for Google.
The second part to
highlight is so far
we've only open
sourced libraries, so
each one of these
libraries that you can use.
But you still have to
glue them together.
You still have to
write some code
to make them work
in a joint manner.
That's just because
we haven't open
sourced the full platform yet.
We're actively working on this.
But I would say so far
we're about 50% there.
So these blue
components are the ones
that I'm going to
talk about today.
But first, let me talk
about some of the principles
that we followed when
we developed TFX.
Because I think it's
very informative
to see how we think
about these platforms,
and how we think about
having impact at Google.
The first principle
is flexibility.
And there's some
history behind this.
And the short version
of that history
is that I'm sure at other
companies as well there used
to be problem specific
machine learning platforms.
And just to be concrete,
so we had a platform
that was specifically built
for large scale linear models.
So if you had a
linear model that you
wanted to train at
large scale, you
used this piece
of infrastructure.
We had a different
piece of infrastructure
for large scale neural networks.
But product teams usually don't
have one kind of a problem.
And they usually want to train
multiple types of models.
So if they wanted to train
linear [INAUDIBLE] models,
they had to use two entirely
different technology stacks.
Now, with TensorFlow,
as I'm sure you know,
we can actually express any kind
of machine learning algorithm.
So we can train
TensorFlow models
that are linear, that are deep,
unsupervised and supervised.
We can train tree models.
And any single algorithm
that you can think of either
has already been
implemented in TensorFlow,
or is possible to be
implemented in TensorFlow.
So building on top
of that flexibility,
we have one platform
that supports
all of these different use
cases from all of our users.
And they don't have to
switch between platforms just
because they want to implement
different types of algorithms.
Another aspect of this
is the input data.
Of course, also product teams
don't only have image data,
or only have text data.
In some cases, they
may even have both.
Right.
So they have models that
take in both images and text,
and make a prediction.
So we needed to make sure that
the platform that we built
supports all of these
input modalities,
and can deal with
images, text, sparse data
that you will find
in logs, videos even.
And with a platform
as flexible as this,
you can ensure that
all of the users
can represent all of their use
cases on the same platform,
and don't have to adopt
different technologies.
The next aspects
of flexibility is
how you actually
run these pipelines
and how you train models.
So one very basic use case
is you have all of your data
available.
You train your model
once, and you're done.
This works really well
for stationary problems.
A good example is
always, you want
to train a model that classifies
an image whether there's
a cat or a dog in that image.
Cats and dogs have looked
the same for quite a while.
And they will look
the same in 10 years,
or very much the same as today.
So that same model will probably
work well in a couple of years.
So you don't need to
keep that model fresh.
However, if you have a non
stationary problem where
data changes over time,
recommendation systems
have new types of products
that you want to recommend,
new types of videos that get
uploaded all the time, you
actually have to retrain these
models, or keep them fresh.
So one way of doing
this is to train a model
on a subset of your data.
Once you get new data,
you throw that away.
You train a new model either
on the superset, so on the old
and on the new data, or only
on the fresh data, and so on.
Now, that has a couple
of disadvantages.
One of them being
that you throw away
learning from previous models.
In some cases, you're
wasting resources,
because you actually have to
retrain over the same data over
and over again.
And because a lot
of these models
are actually not
deterministic, you
may end up with vastly
different models every time.
Because the way that
they're being initialized,
you may end up in
different optimum
every time you
train these models.
So a more advanced
way of doing this
is to start training
with your data.
And then initialize your model
from the previous weights
from these models and
continue training.
So we call that warm starting
of models that may seem trivial
if you just say,
well, this is just
a continuation of
your training run.
You just added more
data and you continue.
But depending on your
model architecture,
it's actually non-trivial.
Which in some
cases, you may only
want to warm start embeddings.
So you may only want to transfer
the weights of the embeddings
to a new model and initialize
the rest of your network
randomly.
So there's a lot
of different setups
that you can achieve with this.
But with this you
can continuously
update your models.
You retain the learning
from previous versions.
You can even, depending
on how you set it up,
bias your model more on
the more recent data.
But you're still not
throwing away the old data.
And always have a fresh model
that's updated for production.
The second principle
is portability.
And there's a few
aspects to this.
The first one is obvious.
So because we rely
on TensorFlow,
we inherit the
properties of TensorFlow,
which means you can already
train your TensorFlow
models in different environments
and on different machines.
So you can train a
TensorFlow model locally.
You can distribute it
in a cloud environment.
And by cloud, I mean any
setup of multiple clusters.
It doesn't have to
be a managed cloud.
You can train or perform
inferences with your TensorFlow
models on the devices
that you care about today.
And you can also train
and deploy them on devices
that you may care
about in the future.
Next is Apache Beam.
So when we open sourced
a lot of our components
we faced the challenge
that internally we
use a data processing
engine that
allows us to run
these large scale
data processing pipelines.
But in the open source world
and in all of your companies,
you may use different
data processing systems.
So we were looking for
a portability layer.
And Apache beam provides us
with that portability layer.
It allows us to express a data
graph once with the Python SDK.
And then you can use
different runners
to run those same data graphs
in different environments.
The first one is
a direct runner.
So that allows you to
run these data graphs
on a single machine.
There's also the one that's
being used in notebooks.
So I'll come back to
that later, but we
want to make sure
that all of our tools
work in notebook environments,
because we know that that's
where data scientists start.
Then there's a data
flow runner, with which
you can run these same
pipelines at scale
on the cloud's
dataflow in this case.
There's a Flink runner
that's being developed
right now by the community.
There's a [INAUDIBLE]
ticket that you can follow
for the status updates on this.
I'm being told it's going
to be ready at some point
later this year.
And the community is also
working on more runners
so that these pipelines
are becoming more portable
and can be run in more
different environments.
In terms of cluster management
and managing your resources,
we work very well together with
Kubernetes and the KubeFlow
project, which actually is the
next talk right after mine.
And if you're familiar
with Kubernetes,
there's something
called Minikube,
with which you can
deploy your Kubernetes
setup on a single machine.
Of course, there's managed
Kubernetes solutions
such as GKE.
You can run your own
Kubernetes cluster
if you want to, on prem.
And, again, we inherit
the portability aspects
of Kubernetes.
Another extremely important
aspect is scalability.
And I've alluded to it before.
I'm sure many of you
know the problem.
There's different
roles in companies.
And some very commonly, data
scientists work on-- sometimes
it's down sampled set of
data on their local machines,
maybe on their laptop, in
a notebook environment.
And then there's data engineers
or product software engineers
who actually either
take the models that
were developed by
data scientists
and deploy them in production.
Or they're trying
to replicate what
data scientists did with
different frameworks,
because they work with
a different toolkit.
And there's this almost
impenetrable wall
between those two.
Because they use
different toolsets.
And there is a lot
of friction in terms
of translating from one
toolset to the other,
or actually deploying these
things from the data science
process to the
production process.
And if you've heard
the term, throw
over the wall, that usually
does not have good connotations.
But that's exactly
what's happening.
So when we built TFX we
paid particular attention
to make sure that all
of the toolsets we build
are usable at a small scale.
So you will see from my
demos, all of our tools
work in a notebook environment.
And they work on a single
machine with small datasets.
And in many cases, or
actually in all cases,
the same code that you
run on a single machine
scales up to large workloads
in a distributed cluster.
And the reason why this
is extremely important
is there's no friction to
go from experimentation
on a small machine
to a large cluster.
And you can actually bring those
different functions together,
and have data scientists and
data engineers work together
with the same tools
on the same problems,
and not have to dwell
in between them.
The next principle
is interactivity.
So the machine learning
process is not a straight line.
At many points in this
process you actually
have to interact with your
data, understand your data,
and make changes.
So this visualization
is called Facets.
And it allows you to investigate
your data, and understand it.
And, again, this works at scale.
So sometimes when I
show these screenshots,
they may seem trivial
when you think
about small amounts of data
that fit into a single machine.
But if you have
terabytes of data,
and you want to understand
them, it's less trivial.
And on the other side--
I'm going to talk about
this in more detail later--
this is a visualization we
have to actually understand how
your models perform at scale.
This is a screen capture from
TensorFlow Model Analysis.
And by following
these principles,
we've built a platform that has
had a profound impact on Google
and the products that we build.
And it's really being used
across many of our Alphabet
companies.
So Google, of course,
is only one company
under the Alphabet umbrella.
And within Google, all
of our major products
are using TensorFlow Extended
to actually deploy machine
learning in their products.
So with this, let's look
at a quick overview.
I'm going to take questions
later, if it's possible.
Let's look at a quick
overview of the things
that we've open sourced yet.
So this is the familiar graph
that you've seen before.
And I'm just going to turn
all of these boxes blue
and talk about
each one of those.
So data transformation
we have open sourced
as TensorFlow Transform.
TensorFlow Transform allows
you to express your data
transformation as
a TensorFlow graph,
and actually apply these
transformations at training
and at serving time.
Now, again, this
may sound trivial,
because you can already
express your transformations
with a TensorFlow graph.
However, if your
transformations require
an analyze phase of your
data, it's less trivial.
And the easiest example for
this is mean normalization.
So if you want to mean
normalize a feature,
you have to compute the mean
and the standard deviation
over your data.
And then you need to
subtract the mean and divide
by standard deviation.
Right.
If you work on a laptop with a
dataset that's a few gigabytes,
you can do that with NumPy
and everything is great.
However, if you have
terabytes of data,
and you actually want
to replicate these
transformations in serving
time, it's less trivial.
So Transform provides you
with utility functions.
And for mean
normalization there's
one that's called Scale to
Z-score that is a one liner.
So you can say, I want to
scale this feature such
that it has a mean of zero and
a standard deviation of one.
And then Transform actually
creates a Beam graph for you
that computes these
metrics over your data.
And then Beam handles
computing those metrics
over your entire dataset.
And then Transform injects the
results of this analyze phase
as a constant in your
TensorFlow graph,
and creates a
TensorFlow graph that
does the computation needed.
And the benefit of this is
that this TensorFlow graph that
expresses this
transformation can now
be carried forward to training.
So training time, you
applied those transformations
to your training data.
And the exact same graph is also
applied to the inference graph,
such that at inference time
the exact same transformations
are being done.
Now, that basically eliminates
training serving skew,
because now you can
be entirely sure
that the exact same
transformations is
being applied.
It eliminates the need
for you to have code
in your serving system that
tries to replicate this
transformation, because
usually the code paths that you
use in your training pipelines
are different from the ones
that you use in
your serving system,
because that's very low latency.
Here's just a code snippet
of how such a pre processing
function can look like.
I just spoke about
scaling to the Z-score.
So that's mean normalization.
String_to_int is another
very common transformation
that does string to integer
mapping by creating a vocab.
And bucketizing
a feature, again,
is also a very
common transformation
that requires an analyze
phase over your data.
And all of these examples
are relatively simple.
But just think about one of
the more advanced use cases
where you can actually
chain together transforms.
You can do a transform of your
already transformed feature.
And Transform actually
handles all of these for you.
So there's a few
common use cases.
I've talked about scaling
and bucketization.
Text transformations
are very common.
So if you want to
compute ngrams,
you can do that as well.
And the particularly
interesting one
is actually applying
a safe model.
And applying a safe
model in Transform
takes an already trained
or created TensorFlow model
and applies it as
a transformation.
So you can imagine if one
of your inputs is an image,
and you want to apply an
inception model to that image
to create an input
for your model,
you can do that
with that function.
So you can actually embed
other TensorFlow models
as transformations in
your TensorFlow model.
And all of this is available on
TensorFlow/Transform on GitHub.
Next, we talk about the trainer.
And the trainer is
really just TensorFlow.
We're going to talk about the
Estimate API and the Keras API.
This is just a code
snippet that shows you how
to train a wide and deep model.
A wide and deep model
combines a deep [INAUDIBLE],,
just a [INAUDIBLE] of a network,
and the linear part together.
And in the case
of this estimator,
it's a matter of
instantiating this estimator.
And then the Estimate API is
relatively straightforward.
There's a train method that you
can call to train the model.
And the estimators
that are up here
are the ones that are
in core TensorFlow.
So if you just
install TensorFlow,
you get DNNs, Linear, DNN and
Linear combined, and boosted
trees, which is a
great [INAUDIBLE]
tree implementation.
But if you want to
do some searching
in TensorFlow Contrib,
or in other repositories
under the TensorFlow
[INAUDIBLE] on GitHub,
you will find many, many
more implementations
of very common architectures
with the estimator framework.
Now, the estimator,
there's a method
that's currently in Contrib.
But it will move to the
Estimate API with 2.0.
It has a method called
Export Safe Models.
And that actually exports
a TensorFlow graph
as a safe model,
such that it can
be used by a TensorFlow model
analysis in TensorFlow Survey.
This is just a code
snippet from one
of our examples
of how this looks.
For an actual
example, in this case,
it's the Chicago taxi dataset.
We just instantiated the
non-linear combined classifier,
called train, and
exported it for use
by downstream components.
Using tf.Keras, it
looks very similar.
So in this case, we used
the Keras sequential API,
where you can configure
the layers of your network.
And the Keras API
is also getting
a method called Save
Keras model that
exports the same format,
which is the safe model, such
that it can be used again
by downstream components.
Model evaluation validation
is open sourced as TensorFlow
model analysis.
And that takes that
graph as an input.
So the graph that
we just exported
from our estimator or Keras
model flows as an input
into TFMA.
And TFMA computes
evaluation statistics
at scale in a sliced manner.
So now, this is another
one of those examples where
you may say, well, I already
get my metrics from TensorBoard.
TensorBoard metrics are
computed in a streaming manner
during training
on minute batches.
TFMA uses Beam
pipelines to compute
metrics in an exact manner with
one pass over all of your data.
So if you want to compute your
metrics or a terabyte of data
within exactly one
pass, you can use TFMA.
Now, in this case, you
run TFMA for that model
and some dataset.
And if you just call this method
called random slicing metrics
with the result by itself, the
visualization looks like this.
And I pulled this
up for one reason.
And that reason is
just to highlight
what we mean by sliced metrics.
This is the metric
that you may be
used to when someone trains
a model and tells you, well,
my model has a 0.94
accuracy, or a 0.92 AUC.
That's an overall metric.
Over all of your data,
it's the aggregate
of those metrics for
your entire model.
That may tell you that the
model is doing well on average,
but it will not tell
you how the model is
doing on specific
slices of your data.
So if you, instead, render those
slices for a specific feature--
in this case we actually
sliced these metrics
by trip start hour--
so, again, this is from the
Chicago taxicab dataset.
You actually get a visualization
in which you can now--
in this case, we look at a
histogram and [INAUDIBLE]
metric.
We filter for buckets that
only have 100 examples so
that we don't get low buckets.
And then you can
actually see here
how the model performs on
different slices of feature
values for a specific
trip start hour.
So this particular model
is trained to predict
whether a tip is more
or less than 20%.
And you've seen overall it has
a very high accuracy, and very
high AUC.
But it turns out that
on some of these slices,
it actually performs poorly.
So if the trip start hour
is seven, for some reason
the model doesn't really have
a lot of predictive power
whether the tip is
going to be good or bad.
Now, that's informative to know.
Because maybe that's
just because there's
more variability at that time.
Maybe we don't have enough
data during that time.
So that's really a
very powerful tool
to help you understand
how your model performs.
Some other visualizations
that are available in TFMA
are shown here.
We haven't shown
that in the past.
So the calibration plot,
which is the first one,
shows you how your
model predictions
behave against the label.
And you would want your
model to be well calibrated,
and not to be over or under
predicting in a specific area.
The prediction
distribution just shows you
that this distribution,
precision recall, and our C
curves are commonly known.
And, again, this is
the plot for overall.
So this is the entire model
and the entire eval dataset.
And, again, if you
specify a slice here,
you can actually get the
same visualization only
for a specific slice
of your features.
And another really
nice feature is
that if you have multiple
models or multiple eval sets
over time, you can visualize
them in a time series.
So in this case, we
have three models.
And for all of
these three models,
we show accuracy and AUC.
And you can imagine if you have
long running training jobs,
and as I mentioned earlier, in
some cases you want to refresh
your model regularly.
And you train a new model
every day for a year,
you end up with 365
models, and you can
see how it performs over time.
So this product is called
TensorFlow Model analysis.
And it's also
available on GitHub.
And everything that
I've just shown you
is already open sourced.
So next serving, which is
called TensorFlow Serving.
So serving is one of
those other areas where
it's relatively easy
to set something up
that performs inference with
your machine learning models.
But it's harder to
do this at scale.
So some of the most important
features of TensorFlow Serving
is that it's able to deal
with multiple models.
And this is mostly used for
actually upgrading a model
version.
So if you are serving
a model, and you
want to update that
model to a new version,
that server needs to load a
new version at the same time,
and then switch over to
request to that new version.
That's also where
isolation comes in.
You don't want that process of
loading a new model to actually
impact the current model
serving requests, because that
would hurt performance.
There's batching implementations
in TensorFlow Serving
that make sure that
throughput is optimized.
In most cases when you
have a high requests
per second service, you actually
don't want to perform inference
on a batch of size one.
You can actually do
dynamic batching.
And TensorFlow Serving
is adopted, of course,
widely within Google, and
also outside of Google.
There's a lot of companies
that have started
using TensorFlow Serving.
What does this look like?
Again, the same graph
that we've exported
from either our estimator
or our Keras model
goes into the
TensorFlow model server.
TensorFlow Serving
comes as your library.
So you can build your
own server if you want,
or you can use the libraries
to perform inference.
We also ship a binary.
And this is the command
of how you would just
run the binary, tell it
what port to listen to,
and what model to load.
And in this case, it
will load that model
and bring up that server.
And this is a code snippet
again from our Chicago text
example of how you
put together a request
and make, in this case, a
GRPC call to that server.
Now, not everyone is using
GRPC, for whatever reason.
So we built a REST API.
That was the top request
on GitHub for a while.
And we built it such
that the TensorFlow model
server binary ships with both
the GRPC and the REST API.
And it supports the same
APIs as the GRPC one.
So this is what
the API looks like.
So you specify the model name.
And, as I just mentioned,
it also supports classify,
regress, and predict.
And here's just two
examples of an [? iris ?]
model with the classify
API, or an [INAUDIBLE] model
with a particular API.
Now, one of the things
that this enables
is that instead of
Proto3 JSON, which
is a little more verbose
than most people would like,
you can actually now
use Idiomatic JSON.
That seems more intuitive
to a lot of developers
that are more used to this.
And as I just mentioned,
the model server ships
with this by default.
So when you bring up
the TensorFlow model server, you
just specify the REST API port.
And then, in this
case, this is just
an example of how you can
make a request to this model
from the command line.
Last time I spoke about
this was earlier this year.
And I had to make
an announcement
that it will be available.
But now we've made that
available earlier this year.
So all of this is now
in our GitHub repository
for you to use.
Now, what does that look like
if we put all of this together?
It's relatively straightforward.
So in this case, you start
with the training data.
You use TensorFlow Transform
to express your transform graph
that will actually deal
with the analyze phase
to compute the metrics.
It will output the
transform graph itself.
And, in some cases, you can also
materialize the transform data.
Now, why would you
want to do that?
You pay the cost of
materializing your data again.
In some cases, where throughput
for the model at training time
is extremely
important, namely when
you use hardware
accelerators, you
may actually want to materialize
expensive transformations.
So if you use GPUs
or TPUs, you may
want to materialize
all of you transforms
such that at training time,
you can feed the model
as fast as you can.
Now, from there you can use
an estimator or Keras model,
as I just showed you, to
export your eval graph
and your inference graph.
And that's the API that connects
the trainer with TensorFlow
Model Analysis and
TensorFlow Serving.
So all of this works today.
I'll have a link for
you in a minute that
has an end to end example of how
you use all of these products
together.
As I just mentioned
earlier, for us
it's extremely important
that these products
work in a notebook
environment, because we really
think that that barrier between
data scientists and product
engineers, or data engineers,
should not be there.
So you can use all of
this in a notebook,
and then use the same
code to go deploy
it in a distributed
manner on a cluster.
For the Beam runner,
as I mentioned,
you can run it on a local
machine in a notebook
and on the Cloud Dataflow.
The Flink runner is in progress.
And there's also plans
to develop a Spark
runner so that you can deploy
these pipelines on Spark as
well.
This is the link to
the end to end example.
You will find it currently
lives in the TensorFlow Model
Analysis repo.
So you will find
it on GitHub there,
or you can use that short link
that takes you directly to it.
But then I hear some
people saying, wait.
Actually, we want more.
And I totally understand why you
would want more, because maybe
you've read that paper.
And you've certainly
seen that graph,
because it was in a lot of the
slides that I just showed you.
And we just talked about
four of these things.
Right.
But what about the rest.
And as I mentioned earlier,
it's extremely important
to highlight that these are
just some of the libraries
that we use.
This is far from actually
being an integrated platform.
And as a result, if you
actually use these together,
you will see in the end to end
example it works really well.
But it can be much, much
easier once they're integrated.
And actually there
is a layer that
pulls all of these components
together and makes it
a good end to end experience.
So I've announced
before that we will
release next the components for
data analysis and validation.
There's not much more I can
say about this today other
than these will be available
really, really soon.
And I'll leave it at that.
And then after
that, the next phase
is actually the framework that
pulls all of these components
together.
That actually will make
it much, much easier
to configure these pipelines,
because then there's
going to be a
shared configuration
layer to configure all
of these components
and actually pull all
of them together, such
that they work as
a pipeline, and not
as individual components.
And I think you get the idea.
So we are really
committed to making
all of this available to
the community, because we've
seen the profound
impact that it has had
at Google and for our products.
And we are really
excited to see what you
can do with them in your space.
So these are just the
GitHub links of the products
that I just discussed.
And, again, all of the things
that I showed you today
are already available.
Now, because we
have some time, I
can also talk about
TensorFlow Hub.
And TensorFlow Hub
is a library that
enables you to publish,
consume, and discover
what we call modules.
And I'm going to come to
what we mean by modules,
but it's really reusable parts
of machine learning models.
And I'm going to start
with some history.
And I think a lot of
you can relate to this.
I've actually heard the
talk today that mentioned
some of these aspects.
In some ways, machine learning
and machine learning tools
are 10, 15 years
behind the tools
that we use for
software engineering.
Software engineering
has seen rapid growth
in the last decade.
And as there was
a lot of growth,
and as more and more developers
started working together,
we built tools and systems that
made collaboration much more
efficient.
We built version control.
We built continuous integration.
We built code repositories.
Right.
And machine learning is now
going through that same growth.
And more and more people want
to deploy machine learning.
But we are now rediscovering
some of these challenges
that we've seen with
software engineering.
What is the version control
equivalent for these machine
learning pipelines?
And what is the code
repository equivalent?
Well, the code
repository is the one
that I'm going to talk to you
about right now for TensorFlow
Hub.
So code repositories
are an amazing thing,
because they enable a few
really good practices.
The first one is, if, as an
engineer, I want to write code,
and I know that there's
a shared repository,
usually I would look first if
it has already been implemented.
So I would search on
GitHub or somewhere else
to actually see if someone has
already implemented the thing
that I'm going to build.
Secondly, if I
know that I'm going
to publish my code
on a code repository,
I may make different
design decisions.
I may build it in such a
way that it's more reusable
and that's more modular.
Right.
And that usually leads to
better software in general.
And in general, it
also increases velocity
of the entire community.
Right.
Even if it's a private
repository within a company,
if it's a public repository and
open source, such as GitHub,
code sharing is
usually a good thing.
Now, TensorFlow Hub
is the equivalent
for machine learning.
In machine learning,
you also have code.
You have data.
You have models.
And you would want
a central repository
that allows you to share these
reusable parts of machine
learning between developers,
and between teams.
And if you think about
it, in machine learning
it's even more important
than in software engineering.
Because machine learning
models are much,
much more than just code.
Right.
So there's the algorithm
that goes into these models.
There's the data.
There's the compute power that
was used to train these models.
And then there's the
expertise of people
that built these models
that is scarce today.
And I just want to
reiterate this point.
If you share a machine
learning model,
what you're really sharing is
a combination of all of these.
If I spent 50,000 GPU hours
to train an embedding,
and share it with
TensorFlow Hub,
everyone who uses that
embedding can benefit
from that compute power.
They don't have to go
recompute that same model
and those same data.
Right.
So all of these four
ingredients come together
in what we call a module.
And module is the
unit that we care
about that can be published
in TensorFlow Hub,
and that can now be
reused by different people
in different models.
And those modules are
TensorFlow graphs.
And they can also
contain weights.
So what that means
is they give you
a reusable piece
of TensorFlow graph
that has the trained
knowledge of the data
and the algorithm
embedded in it.
And those modules are designed
to be composable so they have
common signatures
such that they can be
attached to different models.
They're reusable.
So they come with the
graph and the weights.
And importantly, they're
also retrainable.
So you can actually
back propagate
through these modules.
And once you attach
them to your model,
you can customize them
to your own data an
to your own use case.
So let's go through
a quick example
for text classification.
Let's say I'm a
startup and I want
to build a new model that
takes restaurant reviews
and tries to predict whether
they are positive or negative.
So in this case,
we have a sentence.
And if you've ever tried
to train some of these text
models, you know that
you need a lot of data
to actually learn a good
representation of text.
So in this case we would just
want to put in a sentence.
And we want to see if
it's positive or negative.
And we want to reuse
the code in the graph.
We want to reuse
the trained weights
from someone else who's
done the work before us.
And we also don't want to
do this with fewer data
than is usually needed.
An example of these text modules
that are already published
are TensorFlow Hub are the
Universal Sentence Encoder.
There's language models.
And we've actually added
more languages to these.
Word2vec is a very popular
type of model as well.
And the key idea
behind TensorFlow Hub,
similarly to code repositories,
is that the latest research
can be shared with you as
fast as possible, and as
easy as possible.
So the use of our Universal
Sentence Encoder paper
was published by some
researchers at Google.
And in that paper,
the authors actually
included a link
to TensorFlow Hub
with the embedding for that
Universal Sentence Encoder.
That link is like a
handle that you can use.
So in your code
now, you actually
want to train a model
that uses this embedding.
In this case, we train
a DNN classifier.
It's one line to say, I want
to pull from TensorFlow Hub
a text embedding column
with this module.
And let's take a quick look of
what that handle looks like.
So the first part is
just a TF Hub domain.
All of the modules
that we publish,
Google and some of
our partners publish,
will show up on TFHub.dev.
The second part is the author.
So in this case, Google
published this embedding.
Universal Sentence Encoder is
the name of this embedding.
And then the last
piece is the version.
Because TensorFlow Hub
modules are immutable.
So once they're uploaded,
they can't change,
because you wouldn't
want a module
to change underneath you.
If you want to retrain
a model, that's
not really good for
reproducibility.
So if and when we upload a
new version of the Universal
Sentence Encoder, this
version will increment.
And then you can change
to the new code as well.
But just to
reiterate this point,
this is one line to pull
this embedding column
from TensorFlow Hub, and uses
it as an input to your DNN
classifier.
And now you've just
basically benefited
from the expertise
and the research that
was published by
the Google Research
team for text embeddings.
I just mentioned earlier that
these modules are retrainable.
So if you set retrainable
true, now the model
will actually back propagate
through this embedding
and update it as you
train with your own data.
Because in many
cases, of course,
you still have some
small amount of data
that you want to train on,
such that the model adapts
to your specific use case.
And if you take the same URL,
the same handle, and type it
in your browser, you end up
on the TensorFlow website,
and see that documentation
for that same module.
So that same handle that
you saw in the paper,
you can use in your
code as a one liner
to use this
embedding, and you can
put in your browser
to see documentation
for this embedding.
So the short
version of the story
is that TensorFlow Hub
really is the repository
for reusable machine
learning models and modules.
We have already published a
large number of these modules.
So the text modules are just one
example that I just showed you.
We have a large number
of image embeddings
that are both cutting edge.
So there's a [? neural ?]
architecture search module
that's available.
There's also some modules
available for image
classification that are
optimized for devices so
that you can use them
on a small device.
And we are also working
hard to keep publishing
more and more of these modules.
So in addition to
Google, we now have
some modules that have
been published by DeepMind.
And we are also working
with the community
to get more and more
modules up there.
And, again, this is
available on GitHub.
You can use this today.
And a particularly
interesting aspect
that we haven't
highlighted so far,
but it's extremely important, is
that you can use the TensorFlow
Hub libraries also to store
and consume your own modules.
So you don't have to rely on
the TensorFlow Hub platform
and use the modules
that we have published.
You can internally
enable your developers
to write out modules to disc
with some shared storage.
And other developers can
consume those modules.
And in that case,
instead of that
handle that I just
showed you, you
would just use the
path to those modules.
And that concludes my talk.
I will go up to the
TensorFlow booth
to answer any of your questions.
Thanks.
[CLAPPING]